bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à l'art des tno des
affrontements ont de nouveau émaillé les
manifestations la nuit dernière plus tôt
dans la journée à donald trump à a
déclaré que les agents fédéraux ne
quitterait pas portland jusqu'à ce que
l'état et les autorités locales et à
sécuriser leur ville qu'en est-il
peut-on vraiment envisager un début de
retrait aujourd'hui
alors c'est gérald olivier avec elle un
soutien beaucoup elle sait pas gérard en
ce qui concerne portland c'est une
affaire qui est devenu politique il ya
une élection dans moins de 100 jours et
le président donald trump tient à être
le président de la loi et de l'ordre et
il y tient d'autant plus que depuis
quelques mois on assiste à portland et
ailleurs à une montée du désordre
en fait on est loin des manifestations
anti racisme on est loin de la mort
tragique de georges floyd depuis très
longtemps ce mouvement a été récupéré
il a été récupéré par une mouvance qu'on
peut qualifier d' anarchiste qui ressent
qui rassemble un certain nombre de
personnes sous la bannière des des
antilles faa et qui en fait cherche à
instaurer le désordre et face à ce
désordre
donald trump a décidé que lui il serait
le président de l'ordre alors ce qui se
passe c'est que il ya vraiment deux
narratif parallèle et qui en fait ce
complexe est à dire que d'un côté les
démocrates ont toujours dénoncé ou
tendances dictatoriales dans la
personnalité de daniel turp on a dit si
donald trump est élu président il va
transformer les états unis en dictature
qu'est ce que c'est que le symbole d'une
dictature pour les américains c'est
d'avoir des troupes nationales avec des
fusils armée contre des citoyens
et bien aujourd'hui important on a créé
une situation où parce qu'un certain
nombre de bâtiments fédéraux ont été
menacés le président a décidé
d'intervenir et donc les démocrates ont
eu leur image où on a pu voir des
personnes en uniforme venir rétablir
l'ordre
apportant et donc les démocrates vous
disent on vous avait prévenu avec donald
trump vous aurez la dictature et va
maintenant vous avez les images de la
dictature dans sa en forme de
développement tautologique mais
parfaitement politique néanmoins c'est
en train de se retourner contre les
démocrates parce qu'aujourd'hui cette
violence elle concerne portland mais pas
seulement elle concerne des dizaines de
villes et vous avez aux etats unis une
majorité silencieuse un nombre beaucoup
plus important que celui des
manifestants de gens qui veulent vivre
en paix et qui n'aiment pas voir les
rues en feu qui n'aime pas voir des
émeutes toutes les nuits qui n'aiment
pas voir les bâtiments attaqués et 2 ce
point de vue là c'est bien plus les
démocrates qui ont à perdre avec cette
stratégie actuelle que ce n'est le
président troll alors voilà shing tonnes
envoie des troupes fédérales dans
d'autres villes du pays un des trois
milwaukee cleveland pour la plupart
dirigées par des démocrates
officiellement c'est pour endiguer une
hausse de la criminalité
qu'en pensez vous qu'est-ce qui pourrait
justement apaiser la situation
alors il faut bien faire attention à ce
qu'on dit parce que ce ne sont pas
forcément des troupes
il s'agit dans les villes que vous avez
cités notamment à kansas city notamment
à detroit il s'agit d'agents et il
s'agit d'agents qui viennent aider les
polices locales ou les agents locaux à
lutter contre la criminalité
parce qu'en parallèle au mouvement de
manifestation on a eu de revendication
pour réduire les budgets alloués aux
forces de police
on a même vu qu'à new york il était
question d'une pluie du tout avoir de
forces de police on allait les remplacer
par des sortes de forces civiles de
voisinage va vous appeler ça un petit
peu comme vous voulez ce qui se passe
c'est que dans toutes les villes où il
est question de réduire les budgets et
bien on voit une montée immédiate et
parfois radicales de la violence il y à
une explosion des homicides aux états
unis et rappelons que les homicides
touche malheureusement principalement
les hommes noirs jeunes donc face à cela
trump est en train d'essayer de
démontrer que si au contraire on envoie
les forces de police qu'il convienne et
qu'on décide de véritablement lutter
contre la criminalité on est en mesure
de faire baisser ces chiffres donc
kansas city et détroit ce sont deux
villes pilotes
qui vont servir pour la campagne de
trump parce que si en l'espace de
quelques semaines
il parvient à montrer que depuis qu'il a
envoyé des agents fédéraux et bien la
criminalité a recommencé à reculer que
les homicides sont en baisse il dira
j'ai raison et ce sont mes méthodes qui
fonctionnait pas les autres donc ces
villas sont des villes tests et qui
démontre que l'idée de réduire les
budgets de la police
eh bien ce sont des idées qui se
retournent contre leurs auteurs parce
que c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
baisser la criminalité alors dans le
viseur des démocrates et républicains
évidemment l'élection présidentielle de
novembre donc si je comprends bien si je
vous comprends bien alors pour l'instant
la stratégie de donald trump lui fait
gagner plus de points que l' inverse si
je comprends bien par rapport
si on regarde les sondages récents on
s'aperçoit que la chute qui avait été
observé à travers la gestion du
coronavirus et sa résurgence dans
certains états donc cette chute qui
avait commencé à la mi juin et qui
s'étaient prolongées ou au mois de
juillet et bien apparemment il ya une
stabilisation et on s'aperçoit au
contraire que dans certains nouveaux
sondages les électeurs indépendants
notamment dans tous les états du midwest
qui sont atteints très important et bien
lise indépendance sont derrière trump
parce que justement cette montée du
radicalisme et de la violence ne leur
plaît pas donc oui c'est un argument
électoral
oui on est dans une année avec une
annexion présidentielle tout doit être
vu et lu à travers le prisme de cette
élection à venir c'est une action
extrêmement importante et pour l'instant
la stratégie de trump semble lui être
plus favorables qu'au démocrate alors
dernière question gérald olivier hier à
à midland dans le texas
donald trump a qualifié ses adversaires
démocrates je cite de malades cette
stratégie de l' escalade constante et du
dénigrement systématique de ses
opposants est ce que cette stratégie
peut lui lui lui coûtait coûter cher
pour la prochaine présidentielle où est
ce que on le sait c'est du donald trump
tout craché dites moi est un petit peu
des deux parce que oui c'est du donald
trump tout craché il ne peut pas
s'empêcher de dire d&d des choses
inutiles sur ses adversaires bon ça fait
partie malheureusement de sa
personnalité
là où ça peut avoir un effet négatif
c'est qu'en effet l'élection va se jouer
au centre
à chaque fois c'est comme çà dire que il
ya un certain nombre de vecteurs
démocrates qu'ils ne voteront pas pour
tromper qu'ils voteront pour le candidat
de leur parti quel qu'il soit et vous
avez par contre des électeurs qui
soutiennent donald trump et qu'ils
voteront qui voteront pour donald trump
quoi qu'il arrive
la différence elle va être fait par les
indépendants par les indécis et ces
indécis ils sont techniquement et
politiquement parlant au centre de
l'échiquier
donc ils veulent un président qui soit
respectueuse tout le monde et ils sont
plutôt des gens qui n'apprécient pas la
personnalité un petit peu trop agressive
de donald trump donc dans sa rhétorique
il renforce sa base mais c'est vrai
qu'il doit prêter attention à ces
indécis et si d'ailleurs tout récemment
il a effectué un certain nombre de
changements au sein de son équipe de
campagne c'était avec à l'esprit cette
idée d'aller chercher des indécis dont
il aura besoin pour être réélu gérald
olivier merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et chercheur alips eux